[Musica]
no
vorrei anni la mia questa canzone ci
trasmette dell'emozione giusto chi di
voi per alzata di mano anche solo per un
pochino approvato in queste note una
minima variazione una minima emozione
parecchia ton quasi quasi tutti quasi
tutti voglio dire ecco il 70 per cento
della nostra massa corporea come
sappiamo è composta da acqua e
quest'acqua a subita prodotto anzi delle
vibrazioni fra l'altro questa è la
canzone di edith piaf è una canzone di
una vibrazione intensissimo perché lei
la scrisse quasi al termine praticamente
della sua vita sia organica si può dire
e professionale come una sorta di
testimonianza finale
una sorta di outing come si direbbe
adesso quindi pensate la pesantezza di
queste note di questa di questa
vibrazione bene quella vibrazione che
noi sentiamo ha generato cambiamento
organico è ancora in principio era il
verbo e il verbo era presso dio e il
verbo era dio mi rammenta qualcosa che
cos'è il tempo
vibrazione anzi la vibrazione in questo
caso perché è la vibrazione scaturita da
quel suono primordiale che ha
contribuito alla creazione la creazione
crea azione pensate quanto è importante
questa parola prima sentivo parlare in
maniera eccellente della creatività
voi sapete che cos'è la capacità
creativa e la capacità di creare vita
quando si dice quella una persona
creativa vuol dire che sa creare vita
saltare vita saltare movimento quindi
questa è l'importanza straordinaria di
questa parola della sulla creazione
creatività e veniamo ancora più in
profondità
voi sapete cos'è la cimatica la cimatica
proviene dal greca e la scienza delle
delle onde sonore che vuole dimostrare
che l'universo è fitto di suoni e di
vibrazioni in cui ogni singola parte si
indica si integra attratta dalla
risonanza
questa è la cimatica e quindi
l'influenza che può avere un'onda sonora
crea la materia
tutto ciò che esiste vibra e tutto ciò
che vibra genera genera materia
bene andando avanti su questa su questo
discorso
il dottor maggiore morto uno scienziato
giapponese che ha approfondito degli
studi sull'acqua sottoposta ad un
emissione sonora è cosa fatta con gelato
vari tipi di acqua né estranea estratto
i cristalli li ha sottoposti a delle
influssi sono vari tipi di musiche per
esempio le musica heavy metal il
cristallo di quell'acqua era financo
brutto disarmonico mentre invece se lo
stesso cristallo si ascoltava fra
virgolette una composizione di mozart
era di una bellezza di una bellezza
straordinaria questo dottore arrivo
anche a parlare di frequenze inudibili
che sono ancora in corso di
sperimentazione per la comunità
scientifica ovvero frequenze eludibili
quindi non voce non musica ma anche la
stessa scrittura cioè il pensiero e
questo importantissimo nelle più alte
frequenze e pensiero appunto quando
scende di frequenza diventa parola o
diventa musica però già quando è a
frequenza altissima è in grado di
apportare un cambiamento soprattutto
nell'acqua verso cui appunto il dottore
molto questo dottore giapponese sta
compiendo degli studi straordinari è per
esempio scrivendo sull'etichetta di una
bottiglia appoggiata di una bottiglia
d'acqua alla bottiglia tu sei bellissima
è stata congelata né stratos estratto
fuori il cristallo nel silenzio più o
meno assoluto questo lo vedremo dopo
però semplicemente nessuno gli parlavano
e scrivevano tu sei bellissima è stato
analizzato il microscopio al microscopio
il cristallo
e risultava un cristallo di una bellezza
straordinaria quasi uno stemma araldico
questa è uno studio importantissimo che
sta portando avanti il dottore moto
proprio per dimostrare quello che la
fisica quantistica sostiene cioè che
nella tutta la vita e oscillazione e
informazione tutto ciò che nella vita
quindi anche il pensiero non espresso
può cambiare le cose può modificare le
cose quindi immaginate alle nostre
cellule che sono massimamente
soprattutto composte da acqua cosa può
succedere sia in caso di suoni negativi
sia il caso di suoni positivi quando
tornavamo alla canzone di edith piaf
siamo in macchine sentiamo la canzone di
quando avevamo vent'anni ci viene in
quel momento il pensiero di quegli anni
li scaturiti da quella musica che noi
sentiamo fermiamo la macchina chiudiamo
gli occhi e ci godiamo
tornando indietro nel passato la nostra
funzione cognitiva e assaporando i
brividi
l'effetto solamente generato da quella
improvvisa canzone è andato per radio
queste straordinario ma tornando anzi
andando cambiando genere
torniamo a qualcosa di più solido un
produttore svizzero di emmenthal un po
provato la stessa cosa che ha fatto il
dottore moto immaginate su che cosa
sulle forme e menta lui in grande
produttore e il suo obiettivo era quello
è quello di produrre il miglior e
mentale del mondo
il migliore mentale che mai sia esistito
allora come ho pensato lo sottopongo gli
faccia ascoltare della musica
in che senso ha posto del
torri di forme di emmenthal in vari
punti dei suoi fabbricati fra due casse
audio a qualche forma faceva ascoltare
musica classica qualche altra jazz
qualche altro hip hop qualche altro
genere di musica leggera e quindi lui
vuole dimostrare che oltre le
caratteristiche di umidità e di altre
variazioni più chimiche quello che può
cambiare in meglio e proprio il sapore
ergo ha invitato i migliori degustatori
del mondo uniti a degli scienziati per
far sì che loro the stessero
scientificamente questa questa sua idea
di cui è incredibilmente convinto e
quindi anche questo diciamo oltre alle
frequenze di utili del dottore moto è
ancora in fase di sperimentazione ma
sembra quasi che oramai siamo arrivati
che anche la scienza insomma debba
ammettere questo perché le prove sono
inconfutabili soprattutto sulle foto dei
cristalli del del dottore moto e il
silenzio si fa un gran parlare del
silenzio vedete io
occupandomi di voce da oltre trent'anni
mi sono fatto mancare niente sono stato
anche responsabile in una holding della
comunicazione formazione oltre manomesso
il curioso dice questo ha fatto tutto e
chiedevo mio maestro scusi ma io voglio
capire qual è il silenzio assoluto
perché se faceva sempre parlare un gran
parlare del silenzio assoluto e lui mi
diceva no guarda non esiste silenzio
assoluto silenzio assoluto e solo quando
vai tre metri sotto terra perché se vai
in una di quelle camere anecoiche camere
anecoiche sono camere particolare in cui
si sostiene che non si possa sentire
nessun rumore in quanto ci sono dei
pannelli assorbenti quindi anecoiche
tolgono via lecco john cage per esempio
fece una una prova grande musicista
anche lui grande studioso del silenzio e
cercò di
capire quali suoni poteva recepire
stanno in una camera anecoica convinto
che non ce ne fosse nessuno ne trovò 22
frusci uno era il suo era il fruscio del
suo apparato cardio respiratorio e
l'altro del suo apparato nervoso quindi
uno aveva una frequenza bassa non era
una frequenza cute erano registrati da
degli strumenti del tecnico fuori quindi
ha ragione al mio maestro che rileva nei
boschi in silenzio assolute assenza di
vita ce ne accorgeremo solo quando
saremo sotto terra diceva peccato di non
potremmo raccontare perché comunque è
quello e adesso vorrei fare con voi
seduti una una sorta di performance
straordinaria sulla vibrazione globale
che può avere voce e voi sarete i
protagonisti
io mi limiterò umilmente a fra
virgolette a dirigerli allora le prime
tre file così immaginando vi dalla mia
prospettiva come un corpo umano le prime
tre prospettive file solo il diaframma
la quarta la quinta e la sesta voce di
petto quindi poi c'è di farma delle
prime tre voce di prè di petto la quarta
la quinta e la sesta le ultime tre file
voce di testa sulla lettera i
quindi vi darò io la diciamo l'entrata
quindi per le prime tre file sulla
lettera i
io inizio e voi provate a seguirmi
stop quarta quinta sesta fila voce di
petto
[Risate]
le ultime tre file voce di testa
bene e adesso facciamo un bel suono
organico come se fosse un grandissimo
corpo umano di cui voi siete diciamo gli
elementi diaframma voce di diaframma
voce di petto voce di testa quando mi
alzo così voce di diaframma e continua
la voce di diaframma il secondo step
parte la voce di test di petto scusate
voce di testa quando chiudo in alto si
aumenta tutto il volume pronte tutti
assieme ovviamente si continua quando io
passo dalla voce di diagramma di
diaframma la voce di petto la voce
diaframma rimane non è che si zittisce
quindi rimaniamo tutti quindi voce di
diaframma sulla i
grazie grazie poveri ma avete fatto
venire i brividi
grazie vi lascio
con questa frase di mary shelley
l'autrice di frankestein dal cui stato
dedicato il film all amore immortale
lasciate state lontani dai pensieri e
dalle parole delle persone trovate la
vostra di luce
mi è piaciuto molto vela volevo la
volevo condividere con voi grazie a un
grazie all'organizzazione del petyx di
suzzara grandi professionisti e persone
di cuore
grazie a voi
[Applauso]